en este vídeo vamos a platicar un poco
acerca de la historia económica de los
eeuu en los años 60 lo que queremos ver
es nuestro modelo de demanda agregada y
oferta agregada nuestro modelo de a oa
cuadra con la situación de ese entonces
claro a lo mejor no es necesario
utilizar este modelo para explicar la
situación en ese entonces pero sí sería
bueno que fuera compatible para entonces
específicamente nos vamos a ir al año de
1960 de 1960 en este año estaba
terminando el gobierno de eisenhower el
presidente de eeuu y era del partido
republicano ya lo mejor te hace estar
preguntando por qué te digo el partido
pero la cosa es que es por esos años la
economía estaba muy débil y cuando la
economía está débil es difícil saber si
se debe a los ciclos naturales de la
economía o bien si se debe a que el
gobierno está teniendo una mala
administración
en cualquier caso bueno la gente
sospecha y entonces está en contra del
partido en el poder y está razón junto
con muchas otras ayudó a que el
candidato demócrata de esa nueva
elección ganará ese candidato fue john f
déjame ponerle por acá que en 1961
entra john f.kennedy y entonces qué día
empieza a hacer varias cosas pero entre
lo que hace es intentar pues remediar la
economía de alguna forma y para esto
empieza a implementar políticas que le
podemos decir que son políticas
keynesianas y a lo mejor después debería
ser una serie de vídeos acerca de estas
políticas porque dan mucho de que
platicar pero básicamente la idea es que
john f.kennedy estimula la economía
aumentando la demanda y para aumentar la
demanda lo que hace es número uno darle
dinero a los pobres y número dos cortar
los impuestos para que se estimule la
inversión todo eso es a través de gasto
gubernamental y genera déficit pero el
chiste es echarla a andar la economía de
alguna forma entonces implementa estas
medidas y le va muy bien entonces en los
años de su gobierno la economía empieza
a mejorar aumenta el producto interno
bruto y el producto interno bruto
disminuye el desempleo lo cual
simplemente voy a escribir como que
aumenta el empleo
y además la inflación está muy
controlada
la inflación es baja inflación
inflación esto de aquí es magnífico si
estas tres variables son las tres
variables macroeconómicas que importan
más entonces le estaba yendo súper bien
cuando de repente en 1963 ocurre un
evento trágico asesinan a john f.kennedy
eso a lo mejor ya lo habías escuchado
entonces salió mucho en las noticias y
entonces su vicepresidente lyndon baines
johnson este de acá
y voy a poner lyndon baines johnson
entra al poder
lyndon baines johnson así como datos de
trade en comodato de trivia
lyndon baines johnson de está empatado
con la abraham lincoln como como los dos
presidentes más altos de eeuu y miden un
metro con 93 centímetros bueno media
pero en fin y lyndon baines johnson
heredó una muy buena economía por parte
de john f.kennedy y pues ahorita lo que
recomendarían las políticas keynesianas
bueno lo que recomendarían en ese
momento es que ya se le bajara un poco
al estímulo gubernamental que el
gobierno dejará de gastar tanto y que ya
se dejará la economía correr así como ya
estaban dando sin embargo lyndon baines
johnson no hace esto siguió estimulando
la economía y metió más fuego a la
hoguera y bueno pues no tiene un poco de
razón porque tenía un poco de presión
geosocial porque en ese entonces eeuu
estaba metido en la guerra de vietnam
que claro ya era más o menos una guerra
en la época de john f.kennedy pero se
volvió una guerra súper súper fea
super intensa para los eeuu durante la
administración de lyndon baines johnson
entonces eso fue un factor la guerra de
vietnam
voy a poner aquí y vietnam
y el otro factor fue más este con estos
programas sociales y programas
sociales es decir más programas sociales
para disminuir la desigualdad entre las
distintas clases entonces básicamente
fue una cuestión de armas y de pan que
sucede el gobierno sigue aumentando su
gasto estimula la economía más allá de
su potencial y al final de cuentas esto
causa que en 1966 o bueno de hecho de
1966 en adelante la inflación aumente
muchísimo la inflación
aumenta
entonces la situación más o menos ya que
se debe pues básicamente aquí ya estaba
muy bien la economía el producto interno
bruto estaba creciendo pues de una
manera muy saludable el desempleo estaba
como 34 por ciento una muy buena cifra
la inflación como por el 1 por ciento
pero al meterle más dinero así digamos
dándoselo a los soldados o dándoselo a
las empresas que fabrican tanques o que
fabrican helicópteros esto aquí es
vietnam vietnam pues entra mucho dinero
a la economía y además metiendo más
dinero con programas sociales se
sobrecalienta trabaja arriba de su
capacidad y después eso resulta
insostenible bueno vamos a ver si
nuestro modelo de oferta agregada y de
demanda agregada cuadra con todos estos
datos vale entonces como estarían más o
menos las cosas lo que tenemos es una
situación de este estilo voy a dibujar
aquí la gráfica la gráfica de de de
precio contra el producto interno bruto
real es algo más o menos de este estilo
acá tenemos precio recuerda que su
precio en un sentido macroeconómico acá
está el producto interno bruto producto
interno bruto real
real y entonces pues vamos a dibujar más
o menos cómo estaban las cosas en el 64
65 en el cual la economía estaba en un
nivel saludable entonces ahí la economía
estaba realizando su producción
potencial déjame ponerle por acá una
marquita
estoy acá es el potencial de la economía
sin potencial
potencial y cuando dijo potencial no me
refiero a lo más posible en realidad más
para la derecha hay un máximo teórico
hacia un máximo absoluto en el cual
están trabajando las empresas a lo más
que pueden si llegamos a esta altura de
por acá hay un máximo teórico pero
pensamos eeuu no estaba allá porque de
hecho no es saludable estar aquí sino
que estaba en un nivel saludable de
producción le estaba yendo muy bien éste
estaba generando pues buenos productos
el empleo estaba una tasa saludable y
así entonces vamos a dibujar ahora cómo
estaban pues las distintas gráficas va
de oferta agregada de demanda agregada y
así entonces estudiar acá a este nivel
saludable lo podemos pensar como la
oferta agregada a largo plazo si es el
nivel saludable de la economía digamos
que por acá teníamos un cierto precio lo
voy a pintar así con color verde
o sea un precio correspondiente a este
nivel de equilibrio algo más o menos de
este estilo
bah
y entonces ahora lo que vamos a dibujar
aquí ya está la oferta agregada a largo
plazo lo que vamos a dibujar en la
oferta agregada a corto plazo y la
demanda agregada según el vídeo pasado
la serie de vídeos pasados la oferta
agregada a corto plazo se ve más o menos
como una curva que pasa por este nivel
de acá y luego si va aumentando y se
pegada sintéticamente a este nivel de
acá que es el nivel máximo pero nunca lo
alcanza esta de acá es la oferta
agregada a corto plazo y finalmente
tenemos por ahí este la demanda agregada
verdad que dijimos que es una curva con
pendiente hacia abajo entonces es algo
de este estilo más o menos algo así que
pasa por ese nivel de equilibrio demanda
agregada muy bien entonces 1964-1965
este el nivel de equilibrio está en este
punto de acá que es un nivel saludable
para la producción a todo mundo está muy
feliz pero qué sucede si le metemos
todavía más leña a la hoguera vamos a
pensar que estas políticas desplazaron
la curva de demanda agregada hacia la
derecha verdad estas políticas de gasto
por la guerra y por por los programas
sociales desplazan esta curva hacia la
derecha entonces qué sucede se mueve
para acá y tenemos un nuevo nivel de
equilibrio pero en este nuevo nivel de
equilibrio como se ven las cosas ahorita
la economía está un poco sobrecalentada
verdad para empezar se está produciendo
más arriba del potencial pero además los
precios son más altos vale para hacernos
una idea de más o menos cómo estaba la
producción podemos pensar en la tasa de
desempleo la cual llegó a ser como de
3.4 por ciento lo cual es ridículamente
bajo de hecho es una tasa de desempleo
bajísima históricamente pero es un
indicador de que las fábricas estaban
trabajando
cerca de su máximo potencial de que
había muchísima gente empleada y estaban
realizando mucha labor pero en el fondo
eso lo que causa es que las cosas
trabajen por arriba de lo que es
sostenible que el precio aumente verdad
ahora el precio estaría más o menos a
esta altura
sin embargo como a largo plazo esto no
se puede sostener tenemos que regresar a
la producción que teníamos y que es con
lo único que nos quedamos pues con la
inflación que generó todo esto la
inflación muy bien entonces esto nos
dice que nuestro modelo de oferta
agregada y demanda agregada si explica
esta situación de eeuu en los años 60